it's almost Christmas in the world of AI
and what else could that mean other than
another step forward in the March toward
lifelike text image rumors of an
imminent extra 10 years of Health span
funded by Sam Orman and new state
of-the-art models being trained behind
the scenes presumably by elves but let's
start briefly with the new MID Journey
version 6 announced in the last few days
I've been playing about with it for far
too many hours and the main difference
that I can notice with version 5.2 is
that it adheres to your prompts far more
sensitively I could give you dozens of
examples but take this Roman triumphal
Arch I recently saw one of these in
person but the problem with mid Journey
version 5 is that it might capture the
main topic of your prompt but misses out
on key relational details like something
being bigger than next to or on top of
version five also misses out on parts of
the prompt like hear the stream running
through through the center of the arch
with version 6 at least one of the
outputs will likely adhere to what
you're asking for of course the
difference with even earlier versions of
mid Journey are even more Stark look at
the progress just since 2022 and that's
before I even upscale the V6 output we
really are getting tantalizingly close
to photo realisms but now let me show
you the upscaled version of that image
using magnific talk about getting pretty
close to photo realism I know this is
not sponsored but honestly I found it
really fun to play about with magnific
albe it's a little bit pricey basically
because all you have to do is drag and
drop your Dary 3 or mid Journey V6 image
into the top left and then basically
scroll down I don't even think you have
to change any of the settings to get
amazing results and then you just go to
upscale and then it's done it takes less
than a minute and it turns the AI
slightly glossy images into something
much more lifelike photo realistic but
while we're on the topic of tips here's
another one that I found really useful
instead of adding words like photo
realism or 4K akk to your mid Journey
prompt
try-- style raw and you'll notice that
the images go from again a kind of
glossy clearly AI style image and they
become much more photorealistic already
before you even try magnific gy 3 is
still for me a little bit better at text
but they try to avoid photo realism my
guess is because open AI want people to
know if an image is AI generated and is
of course watermarking its images now
yes I did experiment with putting Dar 3
images through magnific and it kind of
works here's the DAR 3 Roman Arch over a
quiet stream and then this is after one
round of
upscaling and of course with the magic
of the new sunno AI web app you can turn
your prompt into a backing
[Music]
track
and
stands
[Music]
of
un
touched then throw in a bit of Runway ml
to get some
movement and at this point it doesn't
take much imagination to see where the
industry is going photo realism has
almost reached text 2 image and it's
coming for Tex 2 video but there are a
few more things to get to before the end
of this Christmas episode of AI
explained Sam mman the CEO of open AI
yesterday came out with this list of the
things he wished someone had told him
I'm just going to pick up on three of
them as they relate to new stories that
have broken in the last few days the
first one being how he mentioned
concentrating his resources on a small
number of high conviction bets and it
seems on this front Sam Alman is putting
his money where his mouth is he has
personally invested $180 million on
healthy lifespan extension the life
extension company retro is quick to
point out that that's not about living
forever it's about adding 10 good years
to your life it was a fascinating read
in Bloomberg and of course I can't get
to all the details but the company has
just one investor that's samman CEO of
open AI who's invested that $180 million
now I don't know how I missed this but
back in March MIT technology review
reported that samman had emptied his
bank account betting on energy and
extended lifespan he said it's a lot I
basically just took all my liquid net
worth and put it into these two
companies retro is betting on five
different tracks thanks to samman being
willing to do something different and
throw lots of money at a bunch of things
in parallel their main bet is on partial
cell reprogramming and I read several
papers to understand it before making
this video but I still can't fully
summarize it nevertheless here's my best
attempt in a nutshell what it's doing is
reprogramming mature cells by
introducing a set of what's called
transcription Factor genes basically
full of special instructions which turn
those mature cells into something more
youthful without changing their type or
function or making them stem cells a bit
like changing the code of a program not
the function now any biologist watching
this can let me know if that was a good
summary but the main purpose of
including this article in this video was
this paragraph retro the company and its
peers really do think that this time is
different many researchers in the field
contend that the science behind cell
reprogramming in particular has been
solved and that therapies are now an
engineering problem they see fullon age
reversal as not only achievable but also
perhaps imminent samman thinks what's
needed is an open AI type effort in
longevity now I'm old enough to have
been reading longevity research for over
a decade so I have heard claims like
this before in fact I remember reading
an article about calico company being
formed over 10 years ago that was funded
in part by Larry Page they've been
working on increasing healthy lifespan
for over a decade and I haven't seen
much literature on the success of their
work and even the Bloomberg article
reports that samman will not be able to
fund this all the way according to the
Retro co-founder getting to the final
products will require more investors and
going public at some point but I haven't
seen language like things being imminent
before and even the PubMed article that
I read while researching for this video
used language that was pretty
interesting in the final sentence it
said it remains to be seen where cycles
of epigenetic Rejuvenation by age
reprogramming could confer biological
immortality in mammals including humans
but as many of you may know it's not
just samman in big Tech who's focusing
on longevity and also by the way
personally taking metformin to boost his
own health span there's also Jeff Bezos
who has pumped billions into Altos Labs
one of the leaders of that lab is also
using some dramatic language he said
last year that within two decades we
will be able to prevent diseases and
aging now of course the point of this
Christmas video is not to go deep into
the science and test out all of these
theories it's more to describe the shift
in language that I've been seeing in
recent months and years as I say I've
been following the literature for more
than a decade and it's the first time
I've heard things like imminence being
seriously spoken of and even setting
aside the possibility that something
like AGI could Speed Up This research
the 2030s are more and more being spoken
of as the decade that could be
revolutionary for healthspan that's
healthy lifespan as opposed to just
living longer in your hundreds decrepit
of course not everyone shares the
excitement of living indefinitely here's
one open AI employee who might have have
an interesting chat with samman he said
in the pursuit of immortality we are
losing the benefits of Darwinism things
dying and new things being born brings
health to the ecosystem I feel that for
the misguided quest of stability we
often keep things alive longer than they
should be and it does seem like there is
a big split in big Tech about whether
the goal of living for longer is one
that we should pursue in the first place
I personally wonder what Santa Claus has
to say who is himself presumably imort
anyway back to samman who said fight BS
and bureaucracy every time you see it
and get other people to fight it too
kind of ironic in the light of what
happened with the open AI board but
nevertheless do not let the org chart
get in the way of people working
productively together and there is one
more point on this list which nicely
dovetails with the next news item that I
wanted to mention toward the end samman
wrote this compounding exponentials are
magic in particular you really want to
build a business that gets a compounding
Advantage with scale that was straight
after saying that scale often has
surprising emergent properties the
question of course though is whether
it's open AI who will get that
compounding advantage of scale or maybe
is it going to be that old Titan Google
just this week we learned from the
information that according to one person
familiar with the matter Google is
already training its next big model
Gemini 2 so they're training Gemini 2
before they've even released Gemini 1
Ultra but how does Gemini 2 relate to
compounding scale well according to a
report from semi analysis the compute
power available to Google is set to far
outstrip open AI in the near future as
they put it even when giving open aai
every benefit of the doubt Google's
compute capabilities make everyone else
look silly Google will quite literally
have more TPU v5s that's tensor
processing units that they're using to
train Gemini 2 then open AI meta core
weave Oracle and Amazon will have gpus
combined they go on of course on
performance per chip there is a
significant deficit for TPU V5 versus
h100 but even when shaking that out open
ai's compute is a fraction of Google's
and that the incredible TPU V5 buildout
is going to drive significantly more
training and influence capacity than
anyone else on the planet so it seems
certain that whether we're talking about
Gemini 2 gp5 Health span or photo
realism 2024 looks set to be interesting
one thing we can all agree on though is
that working with great people is one of
the best parts of life and for me that's
all of you who watch these videos even
if you don't like or comment I really do
appreciate every view every comment in
this Christmas season and all year a
special thanks of course to all of the
AI insiders and legendary supporters who
keep the channel going on patreon a
massive and enduring thanks to all of
you so from me thanks for watching all
the way to the end have a very Merry
Christmas and a wonderful day